muss man die stimme und überarbeitung
viel spaß beim tricksen
meine damen und herren vor einigen tagen
ist das unmögliche möglich geworden eine
youtube in die wir alle
aufgrund ihrer qualität beneiden und
ihrer natur allen schönheit
sie hat einen zwang rausgebracht meine
damen und herren und es ist kein
geringerer als katja krawitz doggy
krasser wird dieser song ich habe vor
einigen tagen selber höchstpersönlich
auf diesen song reagiert neben ein ganz
kurzer ausschnitt jetzt ich bin die
stimmung unter meinem reaction video
habe ich dann sehr viele kommentare von
euch bekommen die da meinte luca schau
doch mal auf katjas kanal vorbei sie hat
ein video hochgeladen wie sich der song
ohne auto tune anhört also wie sie singt
ohne auto tune da steht dem titel luca
ihr seht schon den song bonnie habe ich
mich tatsächlich schon komplett angehört
mehrmals täglich wirklich der motiviert
mich in allen lebenssituationen sei es
wenn meine katze stirbt oder wenn ich
mir was zu essen machen oder wenn ich
auch einfach im fitnessstudio bin ja das
ist meine mein weib hat er übrigens wenn
du das siehst du lust hast können wir
mal zusammen song aufnehmen
wie gesagt das hier ist ihr kanal sie
hat wirklich ein video hochgeladen so
klingt meine stimme ohne auto schon ich
würde sagen wie klicken da jetzt einfach
mal drauf
schon sehen
wow
wow bevor sie das video anschauen
schauen wir uns erst mal ein paar daten
an und zwar 32.000 likes 13.000 displays
kommen wir lassen hier einfach mal ein
paar sekunden später
die auch in meiner reaktion auf den song
body würde ich sagen dass wir uns jetzt
mal einige kommentare unter diesem video
zu gemüte führen besser als erwartet und
das wurde angepinnt von katja glaser
witz deswegen hat der kommentar auf
13.000 like weil ich denke nicht dass es
besser als erwartet ist aber ich will
nicht urteilen wir schauen uns das ganze
gleich mal an geile stimme
ich bin echt gespannt auf das video
eigentlich ganz gut aber ich finde den
text blöd mache ein neues lied was nicht
so pervers ist wenn ich tatsächlich echt
mal interessant also wenn sie ihn lieb
machen würde was jetzt nicht irgendwie
von na ja nur von von sex handeln würde
also immer noch besser als baby findet
den song richtig nicefield 'ok ich weiß
nicht ob ich meine reaktion auf den
docks song von ihr gesehen habt falls
nicht findet ihr es hier oben nochmal
eingeblendet ich werde nie vergessen
aber wenn es da ist dann ist es ganz nah
ist dann könnte ja vielleicht einfach
nicht da drauf klicken und da bin ich
wirklich zu dem entschluss gekommen dass
dort kein schlechtes lied ist ich hatte
in den letzten tagen wirklichen ultra
ohrwurm von gc-goalie ich bin katja und
kann tatsächlich enorm in eure köpfe
machen ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
warum aber ich fand den song hat
wirklich nicht kacke deswegen bin ich
echt gespannt wie es jetzt gleich ohne
auto tune klingen wird dein lied ist
einfach das beste katja koch bar wird
schöne frau findet es sexy frau gruß an
dich
das ist jetzt der zeitpunkt wirklich an
dem ich sagen muss dass wir uns jetzt
mal das video anschauen zuvor allerdings
wie gesagt ich habe nichts persönlich
gegen katja krawitz das alles hier ist
nur mein humor katja kann sein dass du
echt korrekte position
ein kampfjet position
eine freude ich befinde mich tatsächlich
gerade auch und short-positionen
bisschen von weiter oben können ein
ausschnitt sehen war auch katja also
solcher aussagen ist ja echt super
allein das jetzt gerade
ich verbitte 500 euro dass sie das ganze
jetzt nicht nach oben zieht um ihren
ausschnitt zu verdecken so wie es
normale mädels machen würden sondern ich
werde sie weiter nach unten
wir sollen die kommentare schreiben wir
kartenausschnitt finden ich als riesiger
kattowitz wenn meine damen und herren
wirklich
wirklich hat ja den ausschnitt ist
bombastisch
ja freunde kommentieren ist jetzt
kommentiert lasst doch mal ein leichter
wenn euch meine videos gefallen
da stimmt ja unsere meinung ist unsere
meinung ab was ich auch cool fand ist
dass viele youtube zeigt am echten ist
besser als erwartet ist und auf youtube
nicht gar nicht mögen geschrieben haben
eigentlich feiert und ich bin ich schon
so ein außenseiter ich bin auch sehr gut
wo ich gerade wieder stopp gemacht habe
hat ja ich würde nicht sagen dass sich
jeder youtuber hast sondern eher dass
einige youtuber deinem content einfach
nicht so passend finden natürlich ist
youtube eine plattform auf der man sich
ausleben darf und jeder darf hochladen
was er möchte allerdings wenn das ganze
wirklich solche ausmaße annimmt wie
beispielsweise die bewährten eure
schwänze oder treuetest ich schicke a
spielt an freund
mir geht das ganze teilweise ein
bisschen zu weit in die +18 schiene
katja ich bin da ja nur ganz ehrlich
also wie gesagt ich weiß nicht ob du
damit jetzt auch mich ansprechen wollte
sollte ist glaube ich sogar mich schon
mal im video erwähnt wo es darum ging ob
du mit youtube und sie hat ja gesagt
wie gesagt habe ich nichts gegen kanada
wird persönlich mir geht es nur um den
content der teilweise einfach ein
bisschen zu weit geht meiner meinung
nach und auch einfach nicht mein
geschmack ist ich bin den content
ehrlich gesagt einfach nicht gut aber
wir sind ja hier um katja autotüren zu
hören natürlich muss
also ich bin der meinung wenn man nicht
singen kann dann sollte man nicht singen
aber gut
eure meinung ist eure meinung haben wir
gelernt hat euch heute einfach mal an zu
lernen
wie sehen die kante denn ohne musik im
hintergrund ohne bearbeitung und
studioaufnahmen einfach mit handy
aufgenommen wollen ich wollte einfach
mal direkt drauf los ja dann schicken
wir mal einfach drauflos jetzt noch
drauf los
ich fühle mich gerade wie
jetzt ganz im ernst katja es kann auch
sein dass viele die ich wirklich nicht
mögen wegen dieser ganzen aussagen
zwischendurch das ist einfach wirklich
kindisch ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
was sie damit erreichen wir also soll er
jetzt jemand geil werden oder nicht oder
verlost deine handynummer also bei mir
ist es beispielsweise so es ist gerade
der vierte zwölfte vor drei tagen kamen
bei mir neues merchandise da kamen fünf
neue artikel ein oberst heinz rudi ganz
kuschelig und so zwei bretter ein t
shirt und ein paar socken und jetzt
zeige ich weltfrieden bei mir war es so
dass ich einfach bei den bestellungen
ein signiertes ticker beigelegt habe die
ein besonderes design hatten und so
weiter und so fort
bei katja ist es so die packt einfach
ihre handynummer mit bei ist natürlich
auch eine taktik die man dann natürlich
auch machen kann einfach mal ganz gut
zurück moment wo war das aber da war
und jetzt kommt direkt zu meiner stimme
ich einfach mal und ich weiß genau ich
werde schwach wenn du es mir von hinten
macht maas mehr darum was mir dagegen
maß mehr daran und schreib doch einfach
mal die kommentare im bifang gelegt
was
das war's
dass das war's das war's das war's ich
habe mir gerade extra zwei minuten 14
prix intro angeguckt wie sie sagt dass
wenn man ihren song sich holt das ja die
handynummer bla bla bla und wie bocket
sie gerade auf verschicken hat um dann
wirklich ein ausschnitt zu sehen der von
ihrem snapshot einfach gesichert ist wie
sie vom spiegel sitzt und sich filmt und
einfach fünf sekunden senkt katja ich
dachte da kommt jetzt das ganze lied
freunde wir schauen trotzdem mal weiter
und schreibt einfach in die kommentare
wie fangen wir den gesang ist erdbeeren
nicht peinlich komplett anders gut
komplett kurz
es war einfach komplett kurz ich weiß
dass ich sie liebe und ich weiß dass ich
gerne jetzt real talk das finde ich gut
würdet ihr euch das trauen also
hat er ist dass gerade dann
habens katja glaser wird ein kanal in
dem es in jedem video darum geht dass
sie irgendetwas macht was eigentlich auf
anderen plattformen hochgeladen werden
sollte sagt ey würdet ihr euch ist
eigentlich trauen zu zeigen wie ihr
singt
katja mast einen kalender mit nacktfotos
von der rausgebracht und du fragst uns
ob wir uns es auch trauen würden zu
singen alter also die das dass das
vergleicht also du zeigt dass gerade
videos und sagst es ist krass so du hast
du sonst machst dieses ganze video von
ihr hat den produktionsaufwand von fünf
minuten dass meine stimme ohne
bearbeitung viel spaß beim tricksen
katja
wie sollen wir auf deine stimme wechseln
ich liebe euch bis dann
sie hat halt nicht mal das ende
rausgeschnitten sie hat einfach auf die
kamera gedrückt video war vorbei ich
muss jetzt wirklich abschließend sagen
ich finde den song body und das habe ich
auch schon eine reaktion gesagt wirklich
nicht packe ich finde sie kann nicht zu
bestimmten dingen die die bi also sie
kann es ein wenig aber trotzdem wirklich
noch immer nicht ansatzweise gut und
dieses video hier ich dachte sie es
jetzt im tonstudio da irgendwas weil ich
meinen dass am nail freunde da ist sie
im tonstudio das video hat mir wirklich
keine auskunft darüber gegeben wie sich
doch ohne auto tune anhört weil sie hat
es einfach wirklich vor ihrem spiegel
gesungen und das war ja nicht die datei
die nachher wirklich in den song mit
eingearbeitet wurde passt es eure
meinung zu katjas gesang schreibt mir
gerne in die kommentare katja lehrstelle
persönliche botschaft an sich falls du
das video hier sehen willst ich glaube
du wirst das video hier sehen ich habe
respekt davor dass du das durchzieht was
du durchziehen möchte meiner meinung
nach geht das manchmal deutlich zu weit
wenn du videos hoch lädt wie du
schwänzen von anderen leuten bewährtes
allgemein oberflächliche dinge und keine
ahnung was es ist ich glaube ihr wisst
was ich meine natürlich mache ich selbst
nicht den besten content ich habe das
selber keine weiße weste an viele videos
von mir bestehen auch einfach nur darauf
dass sich auf blöde videos reagiere aber
ich finds echt interessant zu sehen wie
du dich in der gesamtbranche sage ich
meine der musikbranche weiter entwickelt
weil mit gesangsunterricht ist da
vielleicht was drin
ja
ich war noch nie so nette direction aber
wenn euch meine reaktion darauf gefallen
hatte das gerne mal ein leica schreibt
mal in die kommentare doggy wenn ihr in
runter
was ist los mit meinem leben das ziel
von bio das was jetzt hier vom video ihr
könnt jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten mal einen
schock aus checken hier findet ihr zwei
andere videos und weniger abonnenten
zeit könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken
dann willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]